hi everyone and welcome to bloomberg
quick takes live stream of taiwan's
presidential inauguration i'm kirmi mori
and joining us live is lev nachman
who studies social movements and party
politics in taiwan and hong kong
thanks for coming on lev thank you so
much for having me
of course so for those of you watching
send us any questions you may have and
we'll try to get them answered
from live throughout this broadcast uh
we are listening in
um on now the last few minutes of
president sanguen's inaugural address
she was first selected in a landslide
victory in 2016
and was re-elected early this year while
her democratic progressive party or the
dpp retained control of the legislature
so as she wraps up her address uh lev
can you talk us through some of the main
points she touched on today
[Music]
so uh there was kind of i see three
main topics that she talked about the
first of course is taiwan's handling
of the kobe pandemic that the entire
world is going through
um i think it was really smart for her
to really emphasize just
how well taiwan has handled
the entire pandemic domestically but
also more importantly highlighting how
much
taiwan has helped internationally and
reminding citizens that this is a really
uh
prideful moment for taiwan because
they've been able to be such
a global player and because taiwan's
been able to contribute in so many
positive ways
um what i especially like is how she
started off the entire
uh kind of section of talking about the
pandemic by thanking citizens for their
patience with
uh how taiwan rolled out its policies in
terms of mass distribution
uh and thanked people who had to go to
quarantine uh
for their patience and for understanding
and highlighting how uh taiwan's civil
society has been so accommodating
uh and how she's very grateful for for
that um the second
uh major point that i thought was
interesting was her discussion of the
military
uh so she emphasized something that i
thought was really important which is
kind of to acknowledge that there are
problems
in taiwan's military institutions and
there's problems with kind of
uh the public's view of the military
which is something that i think
in taiwan is something that's needed to
be addressed for a while
and she said that she's going to try to
do more to try to kind of raise the
image of the military
while also acknowledging that there's a
lot of kind of imperfect institutions in
the military
um and that's uh you know talks of
improving taiwan's cyber security
improving military's capabilities
uh as kind of the goals going forward in
the next four years
was also i think a very smart move and
then finally
uh she addressed uh cross-strait
issues very briefly i mean she she said
before this speech
uh i think a few days ago that uh she
already announced that she was not going
to actually have any substantive changes
to her cross straight policy which is
as she said in her life in her uh in her
speech
that she's going to adhere to the roc
constitution the republic of china
constitution and not do anything to
upset the status quo
which is what the dpp stance has been
and what sang one stance has been
since she got into office in 2016.
i think those are kind of the three big
takeaways i i have from from her
address okay great so ties between
taiwan and the u.s
have been the strongest of same decades
could you talk about
a little bit of about what is behind
behind the strengthening ties between
the us and taiwan
so uh taiwan and the us have always been
allies for a very long time i think it's
important to
to note that there was never like a bad
time for us taiwan relations
um but but you're totally right to point
out that
right now it's the best it's been in a
long time
because there's becoming more and more
dialogue between the us and taiwan and
because there's more and more trade
going on between the us and taiwan just
yesterday there was an announcement
about taiwan's one of its biggest
semiconductor uh organ um companies
opening up a base
in uh a factory in the us which is a
very big deal
um and something like that would have
been unheard of years ago
uh or how there's more dialogue between
uh us and taiwan military
now more than ever and i think it's a
couple of things so first
uh the pandemic has most certainly uh
shown
how capable taiwan can be as a partner
and i think i think a lot of the
idea of wanting to have closer ties in
taiwan does come from a very positive
place of seeing taiwan as a capable
partner um but at the same time i think
another big part of why the us is trying
to
elevate its relationship with taiwan is
because of
conflict with china so the us wants to
use taiwan as a wedge between uh
its relationship with china and use
taiwan in a way that can
both help taiwan but also um shows
kind of uh to the prc that
uh taiwan is not going to simply be kind
of a neutral
um kind of actor between their
relationship
right and do you think that'll continue
the stronger ties
do you think that'll continue no matter
who the next u.s president is
uh i do i think you can look at
something like the type pay act that
just passed
um i think a month ago less than now uh
that was a totally bipartisan
uh bill so uh the taipei act said that
there that the us was committed to
strengthening ties with taiwan that was
going to help taiwan gain access to
international organizations
uh and that it was going to increase a
military cooperation between
uh taiwan and the u.s and that bill was
uh there were more democrats that voted
in favor
uh than republicans although it was
still a completely um
unanimous humanist show of support so so
you know whoever the president is
at the end of this year in the us uh i
think there uh there is good reason to
think that
ties between the us and taiwan will
still uh maintain their strength
so we mentioned a little bit um you
mentioned a little bit about
china so what are some widely held
misconceptions about taiwan and its
relationship with china that you
think need clearing up so there's a
couple
uh important ones i think the one that
you see in the most
is just through simple language in media
rhetoric
and it's one that you often see
called reunification and when you see
reunification it's a little bit
misleading
because the people's republic of china
the prc has never
actually governed taiwan the roc
so historically uh after the the chinese
civil war
the roc fled to taiwan and before the
roc fled to taiwan
taiwan was a part of the roc and before
it was a part of the roc it was a colony
of japan
but when the prc was founded um
in 1949 it never actually had
any sort of governing authority over
taiwan and still never has
so when you see things like
reunification or you see taiwan
described as a
renegade province it's misleading
because that kind of infers that taiwan
was once a province
of the art of the prc when in fact
that's never been the case
got it okay is there any other are there
any other misconceptions that
we really should be talking about yeah
so i think another really important one
uh that cyan one herself uh brought up
in uh her inauguration speech is the
idea that
uh she and her party are
pro-independents
or that she herself is trying to
actively make taiwan
on a sovereign country under the name
the country of taiwan
uh and that's kind of a narrative that
china pushes about the gpp
and it's misleading because as you just
say
her cross-strait policy is completely
tied to the republic of china
constitution
and she herself has no intention of
trying to threaten the status quo
or threaten uh taiwan's kind of
de facto independence by pushing for
some sort of de jour independence that
would be that would likely be seen as
very risky um so rather than describe
saying one of the gdps pro-independence
i think as you just heard her say in her
speech i think pro-status quo is a much
more accurate way to describe
her and her party's policy and the
reason that really matters is because
the more that we kind of
considered the dpp or cyan one to be
pro-independence it kind of leads into
how the prc wants us to see them as
these kind of
radical troublemakers who are trying to
throw off balance in east asia and
that's really not true
cyan has been very pragmatic with her
cross straight policy and it's because
she adheres to uh the status quo
so let's talk a little bit more about
president tsai i mean she became the
first female president
of taiwan in 2016 now going to her
second term
she probably identifies herself as a cat
lady right so what is her appeal
to the large portions of the taiwanese
public
i mean i i think she's managed to win
over a large majority of young voters
so what is what is her appeal absolutely
so so the
the cat lady thing totally helps uh and
you know for what it's worth for dog
people out there she has dogs too she's
actually a
very equal uh when it comes to to pets
i think she has two dogs and three cats
um
but you know during the election season
she had you know just massive billboard
campaigns of her holding her cat
uh which like what else in the world
does a politician
get elected with that as as a as an
actual campaign poster
but but to really look at her popularity
you have to kind of go back to the 2020
election which i know for a lot of
people seems like a lifetime ago
uh but back in january uh she was
running against
the chinese nationalist party the kmt's
candidate hang goyu
and he was such a unpopular choice for
most taiwanese voters that it was so
easy to decide
to pick tai um essentially not only was
sai the less bad candidate but she was
so much better at presenting herself
that she actually seemed
like a really good candidate even to a
lot of voters who might not
not necessarily have been as excited
about her in years past
um it was definitely a
major victory for its eye but it's also
important to note that
the dpp at zion's party did not actually
have the same success
as she did so their party actually
because the
taiwan's electoral system is a little
bit complicated and i won't go too into
all the details
but essentially you get to vote for
whatever party you like most and
whatever candidate you like most
uh and the party votes were actually
about the same as the kmt
so the dpp did kind of just as well as
the kmt
but when it came to presidential
candidates cyan obviously was
uh the favorite candidate right so
another maybe landslide for this for
this election
um for those of you joining us now
watching us please send us any questions
you may have and we'll try to get them
answered
i'm kirby mori and i'm here with lev
nachman who studies social movements and
party politics
in taiwan and hong kong so thanks guys
for watching
all right lev next question what's the
overriding
um public sentiment surrounding national
identity in taiwan so
do people see themselves as taiwanese or
chinese or maybe both
what's your view on this so in taiwan
the
most important issue is always going to
kind of be this
uh existential crisis about what is
taiwan's relationship
with china uh and it kind of manifests
in two different ways first about how we
feel about sovereignty about this
question of independence and unification
but also very importantly is what you
just talked about is how people identify
and there's been long term surveys
looking at this question for
for decades now uh looking at the trends
in
p whether or not people feel taiwanese
chinese
or a mix of both and increasingly
you see more and more people identifying
as
only taiwanese not taiwanese and chinese
and especially not just chinese so a
recent pew survey
just came out i think a week ago which
there's really really good recent data
about this
that shows 70 of taiwanese
uh based off their survey identify as
only taiwanese
thirty percent identifying as uh
taiwanese and chinese and i think there
is less than
uh four percent identifying as only
chinese so hardly anyone in taiwan
identifies as exclusively chinese not
taiwanese
the far majority of people identify as
just taiwanese
but there is still a sizable uh number
who identifies as both taiwanese
and chinese right i saw you actually
tweet that out
when it came out so was that surprising
to you
seeing those statistics no
um it wasn't because we've actually been
seeing uh
those numbers in polls done in taiwan
for a long time the reason the pew
survey was very cool is because
we often don't see those numbers
reported in
a non-taiwanese kind of survey company
so there's been a long-term study of
identity in taiwan
by a lot of different polls and they all
show the same direction they
all show an increasing number of people
who exclusively identify as
taiwanese not chinese and more and more
people who i
don't identify as chinese at all um
and it's nice to have this data the one
the one caveat
and i said this uh when i tweeted out
the survey is that it was actually done
right before the pandemic
which is uh too bad because a couple of
surveys have been done since the
pandemic started and we've actually seen
that
those numbers of who identifies as only
taiwanese not chinese have actually gone
up since
the pandemic started does that relate to
how
taiwan has been handling the kobe 19
pandemic
it's hard to say what exactly is causing
it for certain but i think
it is very difficult to deny that the
pandemic has most certainly pushed
taiwanese people to feel more taiwanese
and especially given uh china's handling
of the pandemic and the and kind of the
increasing
pressure that china has tried to put on
taiwan especially with things like the
who
uh i think that's also incentivized
people to feel more taiwanese and less
chinese
justin even in the last few months
speaking of the kobit 19 response the
presidential office said today's
inauguration would be
a short and simple version of the
ceremony because of the pandemic
um taiwan's coronal virus response has
been touted to be among the best
globally right we've been seeing in
news headlines that taiwan's doing such
a great job
what's the situation like around now you
live in taiwan
uh life is really back to normal
it's almost kind of uh strange to live
in a place
that is totally operational that we can
go out to restaurants
we can travel around the country go to
parks uh et cetera
and watching kind of the rest of the
world still um
trying to get a hand on the current
situation
um taiwan actually just announced a few
days ago
what the rollouts are going to be for
reopening
even more so so currently we still have
some uh social distancing measures in
place like if you ever take a train
or you try to or if you do travel in
taiwan you have to sit you know
there's reserved seats to create
distance um
and you still have to wear a mask
everywhere you get your temperature
taken at every place you walk into
and they're already talking about taking
some of those measures away because
it's been over a month now since taiwan
has had any new cases
um not ju and it's been i think 12 or 13
days
uh since there have been any
international cases brought in as well
so
um life life is really normal here uh in
a world where
it's abnormal almost everywhere else we
were looking at footage
earlier though the ceremony outside and
we saw that the lawn chairs
were spread a little bit further apart
than you normally would so
i think certain certain measures are
still in place absolutely i mean they
announced uh
i think almost a month ago that they
were going to have a socially distanced
inauguration and you know
this entire pandemic is really taken day
by day week to week
so i'm sure when they started planning
this entire inauguration that was just
that was the right thing to do and i
think it was also important
uh from an international perspective to
show kind of what some of taiwan's
uh social distancing social distancing
measures look like
as a way to kind of demonstrate just you
know how well taiwan has been handling
this
right um and before uh
the very end of the president's
inaugural address she did say that uh
about the future she did say the path
ahead for us is long and we are about to
begin a new chapter in taiwan's story
taiwan's story belongs to each and every
one of us and it needs
each and every one of us a very kind of
warming
a message from her to end her remark
um what do you expect to see the next
four years um
can you talk a little bit about the
island's response maybe to the rising
threat from beijing
so uh you know i think
going off of what she said in her speech
uh i don't expect
psy herself to try to push for anything
uh
that will actually destabilize relations
more i think
we've seen this since she came into
office that
uh really the one who is making
relations difficult between taiwan
and the prc is the prc so for example
since sang-1 came into office the prc
said they will not have any
communication with dpp
which is very frustrating because the
dpp keeps reaching out to say let's have
dialogue and it's the prc side that is
saying no
but domestically i think you know we
should expect uh
four stable more years because i think
seing one is really focused especially
in the given pandemic and really just
kind of maintaining stability
uh and maintaining uh a
country that can continue to thrive in
the way that it has in the last four
years
which has been uh really successful i
mean she also talked about this in her
speech about how they're so focused on
trying to work on economic growth
uh and how kind of well it's been going
even just in the last few months since
the pandemic started because
taiwan is one of the only functioning
countries in the world right now
uh the economy is actually growing here
um probably the only place in the world
that that's currently happening
and how long have you love lived in
taiwan
um so i first came here in 2012 uh but i
haven't been here since 2012 like i come
on and off depending on the
time of the year um so because my phd is
based in california
i usually can only come here uh for two
or three months in the summer
but i was very fortunate to get a
research grant through fulbright which
allowed me to stay here for
a year now uh and because of the
pandemic i actually might be staying
here
a little bit longer because
it's nicer here than it is in the us at
the moment but we'll i'm also taking it
by a kind of a month-to-month basis
and so can you give us some of your main
takeaways
things you've learned since being in
taiwan what were some surprises or
learnings from you personally uh
i think the biggest uh surprise that i
always see whenever i'm here
is just how incredibly active young
people are in politics here
uh especially coming from america um
whereby especially where you know where
i live in america
orange county uh political participation
especially in young people is just so
low young people don't like to vote in
america
uh young people don't really like to get
out and protest very much
but in taiwan there's such a history and
such a kind of
tradition of young people getting
involved in politics
uh a big part of taiwan's
democratization was led by social
movements was
led by youth movements uh and in the
last five six years
you see more and more young people
getting involved in politics which i
think is just
really really cool and something that i
wish uh young people around the world
not just america but young people around
the world can look to taiwan
and see how young people getting
involved in politics does
lead to actual difference
all right sounds good if there are no
audience questions let me just see if
anybody has any for you
for us um
move beyond social distancing uh
perhaps this one uh what's the
cause was the global cannot move beyond
social distancing
um so i i think i can respond to maybe
how taiwan was able to get there very
quickly that'd be great um
so so you know in 2003 taiwan had the
sars
crisis and the memory of sorry
it was 17 years ago which might seem
like a long time
uh but you know in taiwan's historic
memory that's still really fresh
uh and people remember just kind of how
scary that was uh
and kind of remember what was really
needed
by citizens and by the government in
order to respond to that effectively
uh and you know even before sars there's
always been
uh a kind of contemporary culture of
wearing masks when you're sick when
you're
of wearing masks when you don't want to
when you're in kind of close quarters
so kind of the norm of wearing a mask
not strange here at all in fact it's
totally normal uh
not only that but ever since taiwan
democratized
there's been socialized healthcare here
since since the 90s and it's something
that people not
only enjoy but it's something that they
expect so they expect that the
government will step in
and help during times of crisis we learn
that especially again from sars
so you know how is taiwan able to enact
mass policies social distancing policies
so quickly and without kind of any sort
of
questioning or major pushback from civil
society
it's because it's what taiwanese people
want from their government and it's what
taiwanese people expect from their
government
right and we've talked before on quick
take about
the mass culture war about how in the
u.s it's so not normal to wear a mask
outside
you know it's pretty normal it's you
don't think twice about it
no you don't here in tokyo people were
wearing masks before corona
virus took hold so it definitely is
something different and maybe the us and
maybe other parts of the west
um they start to feel more comfortable
about it it's not just for people i hope
so i still i'm still trying to convince
my parents to wear a mask on the daily
uh
it's it's a challenge it is a challenge
all right cool thank you so much love
for joining
us today that wraps things up for us
here
um we had lev nachman joining us from
taiwan to answer the questions
and thank you all for watching make sure
to follow us at quick take and
business for the latest news and more
bye for now